alors voilà pour le récit de l'ascension
de ce matin par ailleurs l'autre grande
histoire que l'on suit bien sûr pour
vous c'est l'accueil de ces vingt-cinq
mille réfugiés syriens
prévu pour rentrer au canada d'ici le
début de l'année selon le premier
ministre trudeau enverra tamarelle
terreau est ce que vous êtes intéressé à
ça depuis hier et on a quand même un
certain nombre de réponses on dit qu'on
ne sait rien faut faire attention on
sait certaines choses par exemple d'où
viendront ces réfugiés serré de 3 pays
là où il ya des cas officiels de l'onu
et des candidats officiels c'est assez
complexe sur le terrain le liban la
turquie et la jordanie donc des pays
limitrophes et sailor bouilhol plus de
réfugiés à la 4 millions de réfugiés
syriens
de ce nombre on ira chercher des
réfugiés dans ce cas qui ont été déjà
reconnu d'abord par le nu par le haut
commissariat des réfugiés et qui sont en
plus de sa douzaine vérification
éligibles à un programme de
réinstallation donc c'est pas ces
migrants convoi se masser aux portes de
pays européens d'entrer de façon
complètement désorganisé le canada a le
luxe de pouvoir aller choisir grâce à
son programme de réinstallation des gens
en pleine connaissance de qu'ils sont de
leur profil donc qu'ils aient choisi
justement il ya des agents la première
liste ça marche exactement comme ça le
nude fourni au canada aux agents
consulaires qui sont déjà en passant sur
le terrain dans ces pays là une liste en
leur disant voici les x milliers de
personnes que nous jugeons éligibles à
venir au canada le canada prend sélestat
en fonction de critères que le canada
s'est fixé va choisir les gens les plus
vulnérables ça fait aussi partie des
conventions qu'elles canada a signé avec
le nu beaucoup de familles d'enfants
mais on veut un nombre proportionnel est
représentatif de la population qui
existe dans ces cas mais la réalité
c'est que les syriens sont déjà
organisés sont déjà majoritairement
éduquer des gens qui ont fui des vies
qui était autrefois organise
et donc on ira chercher autant des
entrepreneurs que des hommes
célibataires ou le profil pour l'instant
époque l'air mais y'en a déjà dix mille
qui ont été choisis il ya déjà des
avions canadiens postés en europe
il y aura un pont aérien notamment il ya
déjà des bases militaires qui sont
réquisitionnés ici donc tout ça commence
rapidement
la seule différence c'est le nom bien
sûr avec les ans l'ancienne
administration ans un gouvernement
c'est aussi le choix des réfugiés on
n'excluait pas mal on voulait exclut pas
mal les musulmans avant ou le canada on
priorise est on va dire comme le
gouvernement conservateur a admis avoir
fait ont priorisé les minorités
religieuses insistent incomplète confuse
et exactement dont de toute évidence
dans les 25000 qui vont venir au canada
si c'est pas ici 1er janvier ça sera un
peu après il va avoir des musulmans
beaucoup plus que c'était le cas sous
gouvernement donc c'est sûr que ça a
créé certaines craignent beaucoup de
gens et ça obama l'a dénoncé parce que
c'est le cas aux états unis pour l'
amalgame réfugiés musulmans égale
terroristes donc pour cent aujourd'hui
le gouvernement pressé de dire à tous
ces gens qui ont des réticences écouter
non seulement on va aller les choisir
bien personne qui va monter dans l'avion
avant qu'on est soumis cette personne là
peu importe son emploi sa religion qui
est les tests avec les services de
renseignement canadiens interpol tous
les croisements qu'on peut faire la
danse et dans les agences de sécurité au
monde pour s'assurer d'un minimum de
risques le risque zéro n'existe pas
c'est ce qu'on a répété aujourd'hui le
risque zéro n'existe pas d'ailleurs ces
dix québécois de choses qui ont commis
les derniers attentats mais il ya
quarante dit
au canada un processus qui est déjà bien
établi et la faut voir est ce que la
société d'accueil
merci tamara et on va en parler stéphane
richer est ce que la société d'accueil
prenons l'exemple du québec sur échelle
vous êtes-vous directeur général la
table de concertation des organismes au
service des personnes réfugiées et
immigrantes
oui dans l'es13 vie
québécoise qui recevront ces réfugiés
est ce que c'est possible de recevoir
autant de gens en aussi peu de temps
moi je pense bon là on vise actuellement
au québec de 1700 réfugiés pris en
charge par l'état donc ils vont aller
dans ces 13 destinations qu'on parle des
villes en fait c'est moins les villes
qui les accueillent mais les organismes
qui foule le rétablissement des réfugiés
depuis des décennies ce concept dont
tout le monde ne sait pas c'est que le
canada soit le pardon le québec a son
propre programme de rétablissement est
rétabli année après année autour de 2000
réfugiés donc yaya savoir faire il ya
des ressources
bon c'est sûr que doublé l'arrivée c'est
ce qui va c'est ce qu'on attend là parce
que c'est même plus que doublé ça
pourrait être presque triplé non on
parle de 2700 les 3000 autres réfugiés
en fait c'est les réfugiés qui sont
parrainés par le secteur privé donc que
sont pris en charge par leurs familles
on les verra très peu ils viennent les
chercher à l'aéroport et les amène chez
eux mais les enfants vont aller à
l'école
ça c'est sûr c'est un défi pour les
écoles c'est pour ça on les en les
répartissant sur 13 destinations ça
permet aussi de d'avoir moins de lait
des groupes plus petits plus facilement
gérable au niveau de la francisation au
niveau des écoles mais oui je ne dis pas
que c'est pas défi mais je pense les
gens sont prêts on a énormément de
demandes de gens qui veulent faire du
bénévolat veulent participer il ya
grande mobilisation et je pense qu'on
est tous et
mis en place pour pour que ça fonctionne
si on compare avec un autre épisode ou
d'autres épisodes où le québec il canada
ont accueilli des réfugiés est ce que ça
reste quand même le passage le plus
rapide
monsieur rénald et avec le plus de
mandats ou si peu de temps je dirais que
oui sinon il faut retourner après la
première guerre mondiale
on avait accueilli 2 2 millions de
personnes en france relativement peu de
thym moi j'étais pas là mais je pense
c'est effectivement pour le canada 25
1000cc beaucoup et pour le québec aussi
5700 donc partagé en pareille parrainage
et gouvernementaux cc g et mais je pense
le gouvernement fédéral est prêt à
mettre les ressources qu'il faut y
mettre
mais les organismes au service justement
des personnes réfugiées auront besoin de
sous auront besoin de beaucoup de sous
d'ailleurs est ce que vous savez vous
connaissez le plein vous les laisse ou
savez dans le programme existant qui va
être bonifié il ya des paramètres de
financement pour accueillir les réfugiés
donc si on va rester pas mal dans la
routine
mais pour l'instant mon temps que le
gouvernement fédéral n'aura pas annoncé
confirmer tout ça le québec veut pas
trop parler argent là pour l'instant
ok mais donc vous en conclusion monsieur
reichel vous dites c'est possible
contrairement à vous entendez comme moi
les crèmes des mères les graines de
plusieurs personnes bon en ce qui a
trait à la sécurité bien sûr mais aussi
la possibilité d'accueillir autant de
monde en aussi peu de temps
ben je pense qu'il ya un problème de
plus à la base de communication je peux
laisser des maires qui sont pas
obligatoirement très au courant de
comment ça fonctionne quelles sont les
ressources qui sont en place donc il
voit juste sept images de ces centaines
de réfugiés qui ont arrivés dans la
ville
mais en réalité je veux dire c'est très
organisés c'est très ordonné il ya des
des processus en place qui permet
justement de bien faire les choses de
s'assurer d'avoir une intervention de
qualité et professionnels sur les
chaînes on va on va vous réinviter très
souvent au cours de ce processus là on
aura les détails
je le dis avec tamara vraisemblablement
très bientôt un pont aérien entre entre
ces pays on parlait du liban on parlait
de la jordanie pardon il ya quelques
secondes la turquie etc
donc on verra comment tout ça va se
dérouler au cours des prochains jours
des prochaines semaines
merci je reviendrai avec plaisir bercy
locaux merci